こんにちははじめ社長です
ということで行ったこの例なんかいつもの感じです
わかる回このちょっと声が張れるぐらいのこういう環境がやっぱぽく
一番いいんですよすぎね商品紹介米しようと思ったんですけれども
まぁねぇ
母校であるああ
まぁ僕も出ない年間や
登録食十分に自慢とかじゃないんですけど
まあそこそこ
名無しに入ってるかどうか知らないですけどまぁ
妻人って聞いたら
僕は多い
何末副島んとか読めよあれ会社さんから提供されてもうほんとにねーよ
なんか紹介してくれみたいな感じで言われたんでね
しますよメイズヘッドフォンです
これはね日本の会社じゃないですどこだろ
忘れました日本じゃない会社からそう品を提供させていただいたということで
koa 迷信
ねっびっくりですよ見ちゃい外国なんかいきなり英語の名器でなんかでも英語を勉強し
てるからいい機会だと思って
頑張ってねこうコンタクト取り合ってなんとか手戻ってきて
ねっ商品紹介することになったんですよオマエラオお前だったがある
聞いたぞの木なで諸外国のヘッドフォンがどんなのなっ
ずっとかねっ
ちょっとずつ集めていきますそう
それぞ箱がすごいなら高そうなんですよ
高家沿っていうか
をも立ってるこのと泣ける感じ
これはもう高さが伝わってきますよ入っただけれ
から
成長されたものは大事で使うめちゃめちゃイケてるッ
こんな感じのヘッドファンなんですけれどもまあヘッドあんまり使わんから横
こんな感じですメイズヘッドフォンさんの
すごいところはなんかで
気を使ってるんですヘッドホン人
あからかこういう感じでちょっと
気を使った素材を
なんかアップ
まれー new weapon にしてるらしいんですごい
キレイのなんか増弾だときで作り卵の形とこいつダメなんですけどこんな感じです
を
まあコツはクラシック66品番のヘッドフォンなんですけどまぁ今会社なんか
ヘッドホンだけじゃなくてやもん
もうらしくて
これもかもえっやべこれが買われてませんよああ
例えばこれのクラシック66って言うんですよ
このグラフィック66は8これ119ドルなんで
これを日本円に換算すると
12000円ぐらいですね
ターズ動画聞いてみます
ヘッドフォンとだ第これでもらって1万円とか人絶対いいでしょ
何聞こうかなぁ会話やハンマー紀子もう広告から音椅子の
あれやこれや例はでも高いんですよ高いからすごいなんか
指が囲まれてすごい音に集中できるし
何だろうねすごい
申し訳ないんだけどなってきた本当に目指せとマーマレードナースぜひねあの多分日本
からでも買えると思うんで
下にリンクを載せておいたんてぜひ web ヘッドフォンさあの越冬ん
ご覧くださいましじゃーん